le 13e forum à l'installation des
agriculteurs s'est tenue au lycée
professionnel agricole de saint joseph
beaucoup de jeunes présents lors de
cette journée d'information
ils sont chaque année près de 300 à se
lancer dans leurs projets d'exploitation
agricole c'est l'occasion à travers ce
forum de dogan de mettre tous les
partenaires dans des stands voir que les
jeunes puissent venir poser des
questions depuis l'installation le
financement ou trouver des terres
comment exploiter avoir tous les
renseignements en un seul lieu et c'est
très instructif pour justement les
jeunes parents qui s'installe le
département en charge du développement
agricole rural facilitent et améliorent
la qualité des installations des jeunes
agriculteurs en 2015 40 millions d'euros
de fonds propres ont été investis dans
ce secteur la collectivité propose un
dispositif innovant afin de reconquérir
les terres agricoles et lutter contre la
pression foncière à clef de voûte la clé
d'entrée de tout projet d'installation
et on se rend compte que 20 il ya bien
sûr 7000 hectares en friche ont à peu
près 5000 exploitables et le département
a mis depuis quelques mois une aide pour
permettre aux propriétaires fonciers de
libérer ces fonds fier de me mettre à
disposition des agriculteurs et
notamment des jeunes agriculteurs et
donc c'est cette aide consiste en
financement d'une
des frais de notaire pour ceux qui ont
doivent l'acheter une prime pour ceux
qui le libère et pareil également est-ce
qu'on est en face de location yannick
métro est un jeune agriculteur de saint
joseph
à 23 ans il compte développer son
exploitation est pour lui ces aides à
l'installation sont indispensables comme
moi est jeune et mais près de mes pas
d'installer à maniwaki dire on aura
droit aux niveaux l'argent aux niveaux
dans mon projet global quoi c'est quoi
autre projet pourquoi j'essaie femis
assembler carrés de serres et pour tous
la suite le feader fonds européen
agricole pour le développement rural et
le principal levier financier pour
accompagner l'installation des
agriculteurs
le département a autorité de gestion sur
ces aides européennes
il ya toute la partie financement des
investissements
le tracteur le bâtiment d'élevage la
plantation de canne toute la partie et
irrigation donc c'est des aides en fait
fait à des roues et cette fois ci le
département et co financeurs et
accompagne le projet à l'installation
une fois que le jeune est installé il y
à toute la phase aussi je dirais de
commercialisation la finance un niveau
de l'encadrement technique dans les
structures de je dirais qu'ils
accompagnent les coopératives notamment
qui accompagne les agriculteurs dans la
partie en commercialisation mais on est
bien sûr de l'encadrement technique
ben non pas de la commercialisation